what's up everybody Mary here with Alexa
hey hey what's going on we are checking
out darkest dungeon now this was out on
early access as one of those Kickstarter
dreams is actually pretty successful on
Kickstarter yeah made its way into early
access and it is now out officially on
Steam yes it is and you've been playing
it a lot I've been playing a lot of it I
actually really like it so I'm really
excited to show you guys this game today
I'm a big fan of turn-based role-playing
games and this is turn-based but it's
got a little bit of well it's more
difficult and there's a lot there's a
lot of unique resources you need to
manage here so like I'll get to that in
a second so this is like the hub after
before and after each quest you're gonna
end up here this is your state this is
the Alexa Reyes state because opening
and it has on it you have over here
the stagecoach like this is where you
recruit new people and I'll get to the
people in a second but all of these
places the tavern I don't know if you've
noticed the tavern says stress relief
under it the sanitarium treats quirks
and diseases the abbey stress relief all
of these these three buildings when you
take your take your heroes into battle
they will undergo a lot of mental duress
and a lot of stress and a lot of strain
and that will actually decrease or maybe
increase depending on how they're
performing in battle and will show a
battle in a minute but when they come
back from battle they're not all okay as
you can see over here some of my heroes
are not in where's their insanity level
to show me what so how do you know if
they're insane so their resolve their
resolve is not very I mean it's six out
of eight which is still good but their
affliction is they're hopeless and in my
last battle with her she's actually my
favorite character but in my last battle
she became completely despondent and
refused healing she actually got to a
point where I would try to heal her and
she would say no if I meant to die then
I died here okay so your character
stress was so severe that she wanted to
die yeah look not 96 out of 100 she was
just completely like she was just just
completely like I don't care anymore
yeah she was let me die no you have you
have a bunch of different heroes here it
says 8 out of 11 at the top there yeah
you can have up to you can have up to 11
heroes in circulation okay and they're
all different classes this guy there's
ten hero classes there are ten all right
what kind do you have
so he is a he's an apprentice Lieber and
he's was he a leper a leper Lieber leper
he's a leper no enemies like Scott he's
got I think maybe he's got like a
condition he's wearing a mask and he can
notice it or he's not like a god but he
used it he's is a broadsword so a lot of
his attacks are very heavy hitting
mm-hmm and he he actually developed
these quirks developed this one as I was
playing claustrophobia I'm
claustrophobic and got very nervous and
a lot of his dialogue was just like I
don't like it here I don't like it here
like just completely like creeping cough
reaping let's go back to my favorite
character she's my favorite
she's a tippler he's a Hellion he an
Hellion who starred also she looks
freaking badass she does look really
cool I love that little image of her
back that's a sweet art style by the way
like mention that the like what is it
paper cutout kind of look yeah it's like
it's like you're looking at a storybook
and you're you have sort of like paper
dolls and they're moving around and
we'll see in a battle you'll have like a
static image that's moving it's okay I'm
very very beautiful reminds me of the
cutscenes in transistor mm-hmm which is
really nice
she's also as good to be compared to
transistor always tried to be compared
to transistor she's another heavy hitter
what's a tippler what does that mean I'm
oh she likes to chill only it she likes
the sauce uh-huh
she's a little something so we're gonna
take Reynald because he's doing okay
just throw waves and waves of heroes at
them I'm gonna take this guy I would
like a healer and then I think I'm gonna
take a plague doctor the thing that I
like about the plague doctors is they
can poison enemies which will also drain
them we're talking about length of you
know taking away health so if you need
hit him with a poison or you get them to
bleed and then that hero happens to die
you're still yeah you're still taking
away health over time so that's a good
call so I've got money so here's so
here's the thing that that I I guess I
didn't read the directions it was that
creepy guy this is the caretaker and
he's sort of pulling like he's leading
your expedition I don't trust that man
at all he's never really explained I
don't really know who he is yet I where
his eyes I don't right I don't know he's
action to the narrator in the narrator
is the man is the narrator who's
connected to the darkest dungeon which
is this crumbled crumbled estate just
possessed by demons basically I don't
think it looks shady though he is super
shady it's missing some so every time
you start a new dungeon your provisions
if you finish a dungeon and you have
leftovers they are gone like okay if you
can't keep any of it and the money you
spend on it you don't get back so you
have to be judicious in what you spend
but also make sure that you have enough
to get through books all right ooh oh no
oh he's not happy at all see that
happened even the books are bad it's
crazy
anyway kidding you can also switch he
read a negative message switch their
positions around to make them feel
better too
depending on like where you want them to
be when your battle starts however once
they start getting stressed out and
crazy they'll start moving on their own
and you have no control over them okay
and it's okay here we go here's a battle
alright these are some skeleton dudes
and they go in round everyone all the
one turn at the music - this is the
turn-based mechanics so now it's uber
the plague doctor so some of these some
of these attacks will tell you if you
can inflict bleed with them I know he's
resistant to bleed probably could he's a
skeleton that would make sense yeah oh
darn it all right I really like he's a
heavy hitter so there we go one down all
right one-one minute down my guy's not
messing around to show you her healing
ability okay
oh so everybody got everybody to get a
little bit healing little healing
hopefully that boosts morale a snitch
you know to heal is really low though to
heal is really low but I'm sitting there
taking 6 - you know yeah and damage for
any hit but once she gets more powerful
I have a more powerful vessel that's
currently dressing right now I'm in a
bar in a bar that's um that's where I
get all my magic as well she's resting
in a bar but her heal does maybe like
six now okay
he's gonna have her keep healing that's
nice good for morale she see they moved
they switched on their own okay I want
him to - this guy all right but he dunno
so that's that's a really good move
because you're avoiding taking any
additional damage when healing is so
difficult to do and sometimes they dodge
so this is we can self heal mm-hmm where
there's little circles in there as there
like a limit to amount you can heal can
you not heal after a while or can you
just heal up as much as you want you can
just heal up as much as you want I've
haven't encountered anything that has
like stopped you has impeded me from
healing myself all right great so some
of these guys the plague doctor I like
because he can like boost the stats for
someone who's maybe having a tough time
okay making the little piece of thought
making him a little stronger confident
yeah that's good oh he he's not
performing he's not performing
adequately for me right now
bone rabble his bone rabble all right
it's just one there's one left she also
has you'd think liability morale would
be high he's stunned again so that's
good yeah finish him off keep him
stunned there we go
cool and we got some relics and some
money okay oh also okay so something
that I appreciate and I'm totally gonna
someone's gonna be like me and when I
bring this up but if you notice um she's
this is a she's girl yes she's got this
nice lady skeleton over here totally
there's a really fair representative of
having like powerful like men warriors
and female warriors awesome in this game
and I kind of really like that all the
characters are like just you know it's
not like a bunch of you know yeah I
think it's like a really nice balance
you got a lot of skin characters a lot
of Skelly characters and pretty much
matched it up pretty good
he refused my heal okay and now he's
gonna die
I see we can cannot die we need you so
he said something nice
oh no arena old no so if there if
there's that fish I'm getting really
dark they're selfish sometimes they will
attack me switch him to the back yeah I
gotta move him back there if you takes
one there we go I'm moving him back
because I don't want people beating him
up I need him everyone that I can get
okay guy I'm just gonna spend a whole
turn moving them all around really cuz
they all move they don't move nobody's
free listening to me yeah she he's very
he's very upset
still you're bleed stupid can you self
heal alright let's try this yes yes okay
damn it damage okay we did only through
Inc on you I think I might be like old
wine or something see look I know he
acted without when they're selfish they
act on their own this might be a god I'm
gonna be my very she pasts she decided
she wasn't gonna attack and she passed
I'm getting so sick of these people you
can't waste turns oh my god guys I'm
wasting turns moving them around because
they don't want you dead back he's gotta
be that he's gonna he's gonna die he's
gonna die you're gonna be very upset
this game does that though like you have
to like take very good care of your
people otherwise if you are I feel like
you're doing the best you can I'm trying
really hard especially with this guy
Thank You Raynald I need you in the
front yet considering your like you
bloodthirsty and insane I know right he
should be up here alright can he like
kill someone
I wanna keep switching them I want to
get her back here cuz like the attacks
if they don't light up that means you
can't perform an attack oh my god please
let me let me attack
everyone they're getting stressed
they're all just all stressed out okay
nobody's doing so hot they're all pretty
messed up they're all just like okay
debuff to this guy a little bit all
right that's good we're making a little
bit of progress here sparklers he's done
great she's good at dodging she is she
did I don't think they've had gone once
she's great
I'm grateful Reynaldo because he's my
favorite I don't think you can play
favor and go like that I'm gonna pass on
this I'm sorry guy why he's useless to
me right now like Ian cuz he keeps
missing he can't attack he can't heal I
don't want him in the back but doing
nothing like what's the benefit of doing
nothing do you get anything you get any
bonus for not we're not doing anything
sometimes when I choose to do nothing
it's just because like I'm trying to
move them or no other no attacks are
available and I just want him to stay in
the back all right get her next to him
it's like embrava lis default if you
don't attack you have a second guard so
it's actually good to not attack
sometimes but it sounds like in this
it's just you're all you're all dead
they're all dead they don't even know
I'm Street i know i'm i've lost hope I'm
very stressed out about my plague doctor
bacteria oh no come on ray no oh oh no
okay all right Reynolds can't die so the
thing about this game is if you lose a
character they're gone forever you don't
come back for fun
why did you Oh God oh my new water up
front that guy's gonna die
daddy's dead Oh God instead did him a
buff tonight
my healer decided Xuan do anything
alright okay if I lose Reynolds I'm
gonna lose my mind because he's my
favorite he's my baby listen you are the
glue that soldier get your [ __ ] together
this is culture this is so bad he's oh
you know he's on death's door this is
very upsetting
I all right what's your plan I'm gonna
have him buff everyone until I can heal
him
okay maybe her frickin piss-poor
attitude will change now have we not
even Oh No
have we not even gotten to the actual
boss no this is hard I didn't realize
that she was gonna be so pissy I'm like
really angry at her yeah she sucks
shouldn't she be healing the other guys
uh they're not available like every time
her can you give them food or can you
not do that in battle candy in battle in
radiance may we find God I can't do
anything this is like the worst
she's gonna wail on us for a while okay
dodge good job he's got some fight left
in him I have two dead guys I have two
dead guys a guy walking look I can't do
he has to be further back to heal I
think he's gonna die dad
they're all dead because stupid lady
here doesn't want to does not want to be
fair game hey a nice mix of men and
women but they do look oh god I don't
mad right now
don't mad no matter this woman she's
emotionally unstable for battle horse oh
god no [ __ ] a few hits but they're
still alive yeah but he doesn't look so
hot Oh God okay I think I feel dude I
need her Tullock stop putting glue in my
face let me do something all right
you know that she's further back I think
maybe I can here we go so I'm gonna do
this because it'll heal them both and
now they're no longer a gesture all
right okay some time Jesus
no no what's getting mad Oh Oh is it hot
is me
I think angry you it to be honest to you
it's a good testament to the game to
bring out that emotions and people I've
seen that a lot with the people who've
played this game that is just
gut-wrenching you lose people you love
and to deal with death perma death in
this type of game he's on death's door
I'm deeply frustrated and I enjoy it
it's the best I love it okay oh my god I
don't want you up front because you
can't heal people when you're in front
see no little Brad good girlfriend
keep him bolstered I mean what do you
buffing on him I'm Keith it sort keeps
them a little I literally can't do
anything okay good good good good good
good
no thank you all right two down all
right we're getting there Oh God's been
along I think we should make camp oh
yeah no campus I'm a little concerned
yeah if it's happening camp is happening
no oh damn it damn it damn it damn it
damn it
I'm really sorry oh no this is gonna be
significantly harder with only three
heroes damn it damn it I'm so upset
damn you red okay damn you know don't we
give you guys for morning so the thing
is we could leave the dungeon after this
fight and get another person
Brayan or we can keep going and risk
like I lose everything I've collected
and I break and that costs you a lot of
money like see you've put money into
this a lot of money behind Reynalds and
he freakin bid it I'm so angry that oh
my god unfortunate oh god just kill
everyone now so mad yeah whatever that
guy who had like a thing for blood how
come he didn't kill everyone he died
that was written all oh he didn't like
blood enough he didn't like blood enough
and he just he was Bennett he was your
favorite
he was my favorite and I'm upset that's
pretty heartbreaking and this isn't even
like the boss this is like some dinky
little side room with a little baby so
yeah guys got a chalice and a fur jacket
he's not even a fairy no he's not I suck
oh my god really elusive though even
though he's got that pimp coat on he's
like Joe feet away from me I can't it
looks like a party animal he just and he
just refused to my heel
y'all are such [ __ ] dad now I'm real
mad now use that anger look at guy he's
got wine lips wine wine teeth he's come
on he's got wine teeth from having too
much sauce this is insane
I can't stop moving he keeps going to
the back being like I'm just gonna hide
back here I need you I need you guy Mike
finish finish him
see she acted on her own yeah it's done
which I guess is fine
don't miss there we go know yourself
there's so much energy is there stuff in
here for me it's trapped Oh jerks are
you let's go back to town and stick him
somewhere and then we can mourn our dead
activity log everything you need to know
is here these are the quest goals these
are all of the big things that you need
to defeat the big guys that you need to
defeat hot
massarde so much it looks like she's
better now
so Gray's out well a bunch of people
died while she was let's see how do I
figure yeah bronze day and she was what
do you think drink or gambling or should
we just get him a [ __ ] [ __ ] I'm a
hooker and then you have to pay for
their treatment as well oh I bet he's
ungrateful as well and look at like the
little drapes and the pillows go over
right okay oh so he's doing this thing
how long will he be there for one turn
so I'll go on another quest and I'll
come back and he'll be ready to go
that's a long before we depart here's
here is the graveyard of people I've
lost facade was amazing she was amazing
Dismas was amazing but can all these
dead people you've lost was ironic i
love the grave robber class because they
can throw knives and they're a little
more resilient there what i think she
wasn't resilient enough apprentice
occultist bled out ah and it says how
they were killed this you can remember a
swine chopper took out that guy
swine's a lot of swine's check out my
friggin mind chopper is a bad way to go
yeah well like I said this game is
really really really depressing thank
you for showing me that we're all gonna
die one day yeah
darkest dungeon it's on Steam definitely
it's out right now go check it out if
you liked this and if you're a little
morbid and enjoy depressing games good
times this is yeah thank you so much
awesome thanks for joining us guys